Most Scream fans already know about how Scream
(2022) paid tribute to Wes Craven, the director
of Screams 1-4, by naming a character after
him, having a house party dedicated to that
character after his death, and repeating the
words: “For Wes”, as the first thing we
see in the end credits. What you might not
have noticed was the hidden meaning behind
Wes’s phone number. The “707” is just
the area code for the part of Northern California
where Woodsboro would be located, and all
the Woodsboro characters have this area code,
but “1939” refers to the year Wes Craven
was born.
We actually see Craven’s birthday come up
again later during the YouTube video about
Stab (2021). The channel’s subscriber count
is 821,939, which could be read as 8/2/1939.
Under the American date format of month, day,
year, this represents August 2, 1939, the
day Wes Craven was born.
This page contains a lot of other easter eggs,
including other hidden dates in the numbers.
To learn about many classic cameos, secrets
on tattoos and meanings behind names on cell
phones, stick around to the end of this video.
(metal music)
Welcome to Things You Missed. When I heard
there was going to be a new Scream movie,
I was hoping that the franchise would come
back to tackle the phenomenon of requels,
like Halloween (2018), Jurassic World and
Candyman (2021). Then, I started watching
Scream (2022) and realized, oh yeah, Scre4m
already was a requel. Also, I generally don’t
really like requels.
But what I do like about them though, is that
they’re basically easter nests. What do
I mean by that? A nest is somewhere you might
find a lot of eggs. In this case easter eggs,
as in the hidden secrets found in contemporary
media. One of my favorite things to analyze
on Things You Missed. So let’s get in to
the Things You Missed.
(mysterious music)
Each entry in the Scream franchise serves
as a satire of the horror genre and sometimes
of media franchises as a whole. As you are
very aware of if you’ve seen my previous
videos on Scream, Scream 2, Scream 3 and Scre4m,
there are a few franchises that they like
to use as a blueprint of sorts. First there’s
Halloween, the movie shown in the first Scream,
which served as an example of horror movie
rules. Then there’s Star Wars, which was
most heavily discussed in Scream 3 when the
characters were trying to figure out the rules
for trilogies. Finally there’s Scream, which
also exists in-universe where it’s known
as the Stab franchise.
So many things that happen in Scream (2022),
from bigger plot points to little moments,
are callbacks to things that have happened
in the Scream franchise, which is also fitting
for a requel, because these movies often share
the same concept of: “it’s happening again.”
So for the third time in franchise history,
it starts with a phone ringing, then a female
picking it up and speaking to an anonymous
caller, then she starts playing with a knife
block, then she gets attacked by Ghostface,
and then she kicks her attacker in an attempt
to escape.
Then in a parallel to Scream 1, a group of
friends discusses the attack the next day
while sitting outside of Woodsboro High School
while eating grapes. We find out boyfriend
and girlfriend Chad and Liv aren’t sleeping
together, like Sidney and Billy in Scream;
an announcement from the high school principal
cancels classes, just like in Scream. But
did you notice who the new principal was?
– [Principal] Attention, Panthers. A reminder that all
classes and school activities are canceled
tomorrow due to public safety concerns.
– [Zac] According to executive producer Chad Villela,
in this interview with Bloody Disgusting,
that was a voice cameo from Drew Barrymore,
who is known for playing Casey Becker in the
original Scream. There are many other voice
cameos present in the movie. Most of them
can be heard during Amber’s party. The first
comes from Matthew Lillard, who played Stu
in Scream.
– Hey Freeman, cool house!
– [Zac] Fitting, considering that this is Stu’s
old house. Several cameo voices overlap when
the guests make a toast to the character Wes.
– Hey. To Wes!
– [crowd] To Wes!
– The article states that many people who knew
Wes Craven contributed voices for this line,
including 3 Scream actors: Henry Winkler,
who played Principal Himbry, Adam Brody, who
played Officer Hoss in Scre4m and Hayden Panettiere,
who played Kirby.
Co-director Tyler Gillett added that Jamie
Kennedy, who played Randy in the original
Scream trilogy, contributed this line:
– Somebody’s goofy ass dad is kicking
us out.
– …which he actually says right while his
character is delivering his lines in Stab,
which is playing on the TV, where we can see
another cameo. Co-director Matt Bettinelli-Olpin
revealed that he plays the on-screen Michael
Myers in the movie-within-the-movie-within-the-movie.
Maybe we should stop calling it Scream and
start calling it Shrek because this thing
has got layers. Speaking of Halloween, there’s
also a reference to its director.
– [Sam] My name is Samantha Carpenter.
– [Zac] This is an homage to Halloween director John
Carpenter. Or possibly Wes Carpenter.
– [Tatum] Don't go there Sid, you're starting
to sound like some Wes Carpenter flick or something.
– The new directors for Scream (2022) went a
little crazy with references to Wes Craven’s
body of work, starting with Sidney Prescott’s
address.
– [Tara] Sidney Prescott! It’s Sidney
Prescott and she lived on Elm.
Although it was mentioned in the original
script, I don’t think that Sid’s street
address was ever brought up in the first movie.
But Elm is a reference to Elm Street, from
Wes Craven’s famous franchise, A Nightmare
on Elm Street. We actually see the Elm Street
intersection later when Sam and Richie roll
into town.
Then, when we’re reintroduced to Dewey,
you can see the list of his cell phone contacts
if you pause at the right moment. One of his
contacts is “Kristy” which is probably
a reference to Kristy Parker from A Nightmare
on Elm St 3 and 4. Kristy is played by Patricia
Arquette, the real life sister of Dewey's
actor: David Arquette.
Also of note in Dewey’s list of contacts
is B Miska. Which is a nod to Brad Miska,
the owner of horror movie news website Bloody
Disgusting, which may explain why they have
all these exclusive interviews with the directors
and producers, which I keep referencing. During
the YouTube scene later on, the related videos
panel also suggests an upload from the Bloody
Disgusting channel; another exclusive interview,
but we’ll get to that later.
Under B Miska, keeping up with the theme of
internet horror personalities is Mr. Morris.
That’s me, Zac Morris. You might be thinking,
no it’s just the father of Olivia Morris
from Scre4m. But no. She doesn’t have a
father.
– [Kirby] Your mom home?
– [Olivia] She’s at her boyfriend’s.
– So it must be talking about me. If Dead Meat
gets to be in it, I get to be in it too, damnit!
Another one of Dewey’s contacts is Judy,
which is probably just Judy Hicks, his old
deputy at the police station. I was thinking
it’s kind of a shame that he never got with
her after he split up with Gale, but who knows,
maybe he did. Actually, now that I think about
it, she must have already had a kid by the
time she was hitting on Dewey in Scre4m so…
that’s weird.
We actually see her list of contacts too,
and you can spot more Wes Craven related homages.
Tina G represents Tina Gray from the original
Nightmare on Elm Street. Leroy is a character
from Craven’s 1991 film, The People Under
The Stairs. Nancy T, of course, is Nancy Thompson,
the main girl from A Nightmare on Elm Street.
B Adams is Brandon Adams, the actor who played
Fool in The People Under The Stairs.
Under her son, there are three deputies listed.
Deputy Vinson and Deputy Farney are actual
characters in the movie. Deputy Keith is not,
I’m guessing this is a crew reference easter
egg, because the movie’s production designer
is named Chad Keith.
For all the Wes Craven related easter eggs,
it seems like there’s only one easter egg
related to Kevin Williamson, the screenwriter
of Screams 1, 2 and 4. It comes when Tara
is in the hospital watching an episode of
Dawson’s Creek. This is Season 1 Episode
11: The Scare, which was written by Williamson,
and the episode itself is kind of spoof of
the original Scream. Like I said: there are
a lot of layers to this.
We’re not done with the Wes Craven easter
eggs though. I’ll be continuing to analyze
those, and Richie’s big slip up, that would
have given him away as the killer if only
his girlfriend had noticed.
(impact)
(chill dark music)
Throughout the movie, we see a couple of memorials
to past characters. Dewey has a box dedicated
to his sister, Tatum; and Martha has a home
theater dedicated to her brother, Randy. On
the mantle there’s also a photo of a movie
theater marquee with three movies playing:
A Nightmare on Elm Street, The Hills Have
Eyes and Last House on the Left -- all Wes
Craven directed films.
Sam Carpenter is essentially the new Sidney
Prescott in this movie. Much like Sidney’s
father in the original, we learn Sam’s mom
is out of town. Both of their mothers are
cheaters, and both characters have some psychological
issues caused by Billy Loomis -- Sidney because
Billy killed her mother, and Sam because Billy
is her real father. Throughout the series
I’ve discussed how Sidney shares similarities
with Halloween’s protagonist Laurie Strode.
Sam takes after her as well. Laurie was a
babysitter in the original Halloween, and
it turns out Sam has some experience in childcare
as well.
– [Sam] There are Chad and Mindy, the twins. And
Wes. I used to babysit them all.
– The first victim to die this time around is
Vince, who we eventually learn to be Stu Macher’s
nephew. In a requel, everyone has to have
some dumb reason to be related to legacy characters.
There’s actually a little clue about this
in the opening scene, where Tara looks up
the cast of the original Stab on her phone.
There’s a new addition here, a cast member
who wasn’t specified back in Scream 2, and
that is Vince Vaughn playing the role of Stu
Macher. So the names Vince and Stu are kind
of linked from the beginning.
There’s also a detail on the hood of Vince’s
car. Not only a movie detail, but like an
actual car detail. The words: Six Pack are
written there, perhaps a hint that we’ll
be seeing a sixth movie. Also this guy parked
in front of him is parked in front of a fire
hydrant. Come on man, the cops are right there.
Vince also has a Jason tattoo. This is probably
a red herring to make the audience think he
might be the killer, considering the line
Richie had earlier.
– And I gotta make sure we don’t get sliced
up by some lunatic who saw Friday the 13th
and thought, ‘you know what? That Jason
guy, he’s got some pretty solid ideas.’
– [Zac] Of course, Vince ends up being a victim, not
a killer. During his death scene, we hear
the song Red Right Hand, which appeared in
every Scream movie besides Scre4m, so it’s
good to see it back on rotation here. Ghostface
actually takes out Vince with his own switchblade,
not the usual Ghostface knife. I’m guessing
this is just another red herring though, to
make it look like Vince was somehow connected.
Finally after like 35 minutes, we see Sidney
Prescott. She’s a runner now, which seems
like a reasonable hobby after a lifetime of
being chased by psychopaths, and she finally
owns a cell phone. She never had one in Scre4m,
but seeing as how that didn’t prevent her
from being targeted by the next Ghostface,
she probably decided to just cave in and get one.
Dewey mentions that she’s married to someone
named Mark. There is a Mark in the Scream
franchise, that is, Detective Mark Kincaid,
the cop from Scream 3 who weirdly came back
to her house and watched movies with the trio
at the end. One of the Bloody Disgusting articles
I mentioned earlier addresses this; the executive
producer confirms that Sidney’s husband
is indeed Mark Kincaid. I can’t say this
fully makes sense to me, because where was
he in Scre4m and where is he now? And why
is Sidney’s name still Sidney Prescott?
I’m guessing she still wanted to take advantage
of the notoriety of her name for her career
as an author.
The original Scream featured a scene known
as the video store scene, where Randy speculates
on who the killer might be. Every subsequent
sequel so far has had its own version of the video
store scene. This time, it’s the Randy Meeks
Memorial Theater scene, and Mindy, the new
Randy, fills the gang in on her ideas about
who might be guilty.
At one point during this scene, Dewey refers
to Stu Macher as “A real Looney Tune.”
This may be a reference to the fact that Stu
was in the 2003 movie: Looney Tunes: Back
in Action, where he plays himself, Matthew
Lillard arguing, with Shaggy (also voiced
by Lillard) about the quality of his performance
in Scooby-Doo: The Movie; a scene probably
meta enough to be in a Scream movie, if we’re
being honest.
In the background, there’s a Vertigo poster.
This is now the third Scream movie in a row
to reference Vertigo, starting with Sarah’s
line in Scream 3, and this poster in Scre4m.
Vertigo is directed by Alfred Hitchcock, who
borderline invented the slasher genre with
his movie: Psycho. Psycho has been referenced
in every Scream movie, and that continues
here, with this poster, Amber imitating the
Psycho soundtrack as she gestures her knife…
– Ee, ee, ee!
– …One of the Ghostface killers even directly
cites the movie this time around.
– [Killer] Ever seen the movie Psycho?
– And then we cut directly to this shot, where
Wes is taking a shower. It’s the same camera
angle used in the shower scene from Psycho
and subsequently, the shower scene from Stab
in the second Scream.
The next character to die is Wes. As I mentioned,
he gets out of the shower and explores around
downstairs. In the kitchen there’s a note
from his mom. “Wes, Lemon squares in the
fridge. ♥ Mom”.
This is a callback to Judy’s famous lemon
squares, which she made for Dewey in Scre4m.
– [Judy] Sheriff, you’re not cheatin’ on your wife if
you eat my lemon square.
– The ones that Gale found disgusting.
– [Gale] Your lemon squares taste like ***.
Speaking
of whom, she returns to the story by stepping out of this KQIS 6 news van. It’s the same
station that Gale worked for in Scream, but
ever since then, she’s worked other jobs
such as uptodate, 60 Minutes II, Total Entertainment,
and she even went rogue for a while. Seeing
her back at her original station is exactly
the choice you’d expect from a requel looking
not to upset the status quo.
At this point, Dewey and Gale are divorced,
an event we already saw brewing in Scre4m,
but it sounds like their divorce went exactly
like their break-up in between Scream 2 and
Scream 3: Gale gets an important job opportunity
in a big city and the two can’t make it
work long distance. Dewey belongs in Woodsboro,
Gale belongs in a big city reporter job. Once
again, history seems to be repeating itself
with these two.
Despite Gale being back in her old job, the
underlying theme about the media and its effect
on real world violence is not as present in the
new Scream like it was in the first four movies.
We do get a little bit of discourse about
the entertainment news industry at the end,
where Richie seems to imply he was driven
to the brink partly by the media blaming the
fans for the poor reception of the new Stab
movie, but I see that as just one aspect of
a bigger conversation around this idea of
toxic fandom.
So what is toxic fandom? Is it real? Is it
a problem? Should we be worried about it?
The most agreed upon definition reads: When
a person believes they have the only correct
way of appreciating certain content. They
will attack other fans that disagree with
them even if they are discussing a topic the
toxic fan knows little about or has only heard
from second-hand sources.
I will add that it seems that “toxic fandom”
has also become a buzzword used by journalists
or salty creators to try to get clicks and
sway a narrative. For example, let’s say
a new movie from a popular franchise comes
out and it’s bad. Those involved might soon
be crying about “toxic fandom” to try
to make all criticisms look invalid. I’m
sure there are fans in those cases who dislike
that new movie merely because it does not
fit their belief about what that franchise
should be like, but that does not make the
entire fandom toxic, and it shouldn’t invalidate
good criticisms based on the quality of the
work.
So is it a problem, should we be worried about
it? At the end of the day, it’s all online
discourse. There’s no reason to take it
that seriously. I feel like I can offer a
unique perspective here as someone who is
both a fan and a creator. As a fan, I try
to separate my bias from my critique. For
example, I don’t really like the concept
of Toy Story 4, because I think the third
was such a perfect ending. But I don’t think
it’s a bad movie. I recognize that it’s
well made for what it is. But when something
is bad, I think it’s important to be vocal
about it in a constructive way. As a fan,
it shows that you care, and a good creator
will take quality criticism into account for
future work.
As a creator, you have to be able to separate
good criticism from comments by those who
were never going to like your content in the
first place. And that brings us to my favorite
cameo in the movie, the Dead Meat cameo, and
this webpage has more hidden content than
you could possibly imagine.
(impact)
(intense music)
For those unaware, the couple behind the “Film
Fails” channel, which Richie can be seen
watching on his laptop, is actually James
A Janisse and his wife, Chelsea -- the hosts
of YouTube biggest horror movie channel, Dead
Meat, who we can actually see a real upload
from in the recommended bar on the right.
It struck me as strange that they would use
a made-up brand for their channel, because
this is a Scream movie. All of the movies
and shows referenced tend to be real movies
and shows from our world, the only exception
being Stab, which is a stand-in for a real
franchise: the Scream franchise.
I figured I might as well go straight to the
source on this one, because I can, so I asked
James why that might be. This is what he had
to say: “Mostly cause we're being a-holes
in it. It's a parody of more toxic YouTube
channels that cover movies, it's not meant
to be us or Dead Meat.” I think this is
a great answer, because it fits right in with
what I was saying earlier about toxic fandom.
These Film Fails characters aren’t saying
anything constructive about the movie, they’re
basically just pouting that it’s not the
Stab that they know and are comfortable with.
And when I think more about it, there is precedent
for this. Sunrise Studios doesn’t exist,
it was just a parody of a predatory movie
studio. KQIS 6 doesn’t exist either, it’s
a parody of bloodthirsty journalism.
Film Fails, more specifically, seems to parody
YouTube channels that screeched about Star
Wars: The Last Jedi in 2017, judging by that
Dead Meat upload on the side: “Rian Johnson
on Reinventing Stab”. Rian Johnson was the
director of that very heavily debated Star
Wars title, and was often the target of that
vitriol from fans and content creators. I’m
sure there are many people that would like
you to believe that The Last Jedi was divisive
or controversial, but if you actually look
at the ratings, most people found it to be
very average.
I already talked about Film Fails’s subscriber
count being Wes Craven’s birthday, but the
view count is also significant. It has 122,096
views; 12/20/96. December 20th, 1996 was the
release date of the original Scream. Then
there’s the like to dislike ratio. It has
1,117 likes and 20 dislikes; 11/17/20 or November
17th, 2020 was the day that production wrapped
on Scream 2022. Thanks to Richie for using
the Return YouTube Dislike extension so we
could see that one.
On the side, there’s a video from Bloody
Disgusting’s YouTube channel that I mentioned
earlier. It’s titled: “Interview with
Woodsboro Survivor Kirby Reed!” Kirby was
a major character in the fourth movie, and
up until now, we were lead to believe that
she didn’t make it, so this is actually
big news!
The fourth video is called “Not My STAB!
Join the StabHead Army and #RedoStab2021!!”
and it’s uploaded by a channel called StabHead.
There’s a bit of a story behind this, so
grab some popcorn. Dreadit is the name of
the horror movie community on Reddit. Mindy
actually mentions it when she’s explaining
the fan contempt for Stab 8.
– You go on 4chan and Dreadit, all they’re
talking about is how Stab 8 pissed on their
childhoods.
– To promote Scream (2022)’s release, the
team behind the movie held an ask-me-anything
session on Dreadit. One user, named StabHead asked, “Did
any of the actors go above and beyond to prepare
for their roles?” Their reply said: “We
were meeting with Jack to talk about his character
and he told us that he had created a Reddit
account under the name StabHead to… ...wait
a minute… WE LOVE YOU JACK QUAID!!!”
Necessary information: Jack Quaid is the actor
who played Richie, the second Ghostface killer.
The account shows him commenting on topics
like Halloween, The Last Jedi, and of course,
Scream.
So the way I see it, StabHead is actually
Richie’s online persona. He was the one
to create this channel and upload this video.
Amber even mentions during the finale that
she met Richie on the Stab subreddit. Under
the StabHead upload, there’s one more video
of importance. “Did the real-life Stu Macher
survive?” As I mentioned in my Scream 3
video, the original plan for that movie was
to have Stu return as the villain, but since
this was right after Columbine, producers
decided it was not the best idea to have a
high school revenge seeker right now. But
this video title suggests that maybe having
Stu return in the future is not yet out of
the question. If he is alive, he’s been
in prison for about 25 years now. Although
Stu himself isn’t in the movie, his actor
has yet another vocal cameo here as the voice
of the new silver-faced Ghostface.
– This sh*t is lit!
– One of the common complaints about the new
Ghostface in Stab (2021) is his new weapon:
a flamethrower. Ironically, the new Ghostface
in this movie ends up getting herself
lit on fire. The link to Film Fails’s merch
store is hastaelfuego.org -- Spanish for until
the fire, which could also be a clue about
Amber’s fate. When she has her one last
scare moment at the end, she’s covered in
burn scars, very reminiscent of Freddy Krueger.
You can bet that that was by design.
About mid-way through the film, the deaths
of Judy and Wes are discovered, and Sam realizes
her sister may be in trouble at the hospital,
so she gives Richie a call to check on her,
and hears an unexpected voice on the other
line.
– Hello Samantha. Richie can’t come to
the phone right now. He’s finding out what
happens to people who stick their noses in
business that doesn’t concern them.
– It reminds me of Jigsaw re-recording Daniel
Matthews voicemail greeting in Saw 2.
– [Jigsaw] You’ve reached Daniel's phone. He is
not in right now.
– I love a good horror movie voicemail greeting.
If this was the fourth movie, which had a
lot of Saw references, this might be an intentional
nod to Saw, but this is the fifth movie, which
focuses more on the so-called “elevated
horror” genre. For example, Tara’s favorite
movie is the The Babadook and she begs to
be quizzed on the gems of the mid-to-late
10s.
– [Tara] Ask me about It Follows. Ask me
about Hereditary. Ask me about The VVitch.
– She’s got really good taste! She describes
elevated horror as being “scary but with
complex emotional and thematic underpinnings”,
not just cheesy jump scares, which Richie,
as a fan of Stab, isn’t thrilled with.
– [caller] Sounds kind of boring to me.
– And in the Home Theater scene, Stab’s slasher
stylings and “elevated horror” are painted
to be opposites. A major reason cited for
fans not liking the newest Stab movie was
the “crammed in social commentary”. So
Richie was upset that his favorite franchise
was trying to ride the trendy wave of elevated
horror, and set out to craft his own entry
more in line with the original by doing a
requel. The huge gaping question that leaves
is: isn’t that exactly what Jill already
tried to do? And yes, it is, the only difference
was their motivations. Jill did it for fame,
but Richie and Amber just wanted to motivate
the creation of another Stab movie -- it
doesn’t seem like being the star was as
important to them.
Even if we are to give them the benefit of
the doubt and say that these killers are an
homage to Scre4m, rather than copying it,
there are still a couple of details necessary
to make it make sense, which I didn’t fully
realize on my first viewing. The first is
that there is no Stab movie based on Scre4m.
If there was, Richie and Amber probably wouldn’t
have felt the need to make a new one. At the
time of Scre4m there are 7 Stab movies, and
in this movie, there’s only one new one,
hence the #RedoStab8.
Then, there’s the fact that the original
Scream, and really all the Scream movies do
feature some kind of social commentary -- which
I’ve taken time to discuss in each of my
Things You Missed™ videos. So why would Richie
be upset about the new Stab having social
commentary? This is because in the Scream
universe, the Stab movies are considered non-fiction.
Nobody is making up the plot, so nothing that
happens qualifies as commentary.
– Because that’s how you make a great
Stab movie, Sam. “Based on actual events”.
– And this ties right back into the theme of
toxic fandom: Richie believes each Stab movie
must be like the original. That’s why there
are so many repeated elements from the original
Scream. Like when Tara is trying to defend
herself at the hospital.
(Tara grunts)
– Ow! Ahh! God dammnit.
Did you hit me with a phone?
– LOOKOUT!
– Must have been thrilling for Richie to be
reliving events from the original Stab.
– [Sidney] You’ve gotta find me first you pansy-***
momma’s boy!
– [Billy] ****
– [Stu] You ****ing hit me with a phone, ****.
– In some cases lines are nearly lifted directly
from a previous movie.
– [caller] You think you're still the star.
– [Sidney] This isn't a f*cking movie!
– [caller] It will be.
– [Sam] This isn’t a f*cking movie.
– [Richie] No, but it will be…
– The final act features plenty more references,
some of which you might have noticed, but
you probably missed this tiny detail, which
was the reason Mindy was able to survive where
others did not.
– Welcome to Act 3.
– RUN!
(impact)
(dark music)
– Before we get to the final act, let’s talk
about Dewey. His fatal mistake is shooting
Amber’s bulletproof armor rather than hitting
her in the head. He realizes it a little too
late. In Scream 3 he makes the same mistake
with Roman, but Sidney is there to remind
him to aim for the head. This time she isn’t,
and Dewey pays the price.
Given Dewey’s ability to survive seemingly
fatal blows in the past, I wasn’t convinced
that he was really done for this time. We’ve
seen this scene before. However, the more
I look at it, the more I think he really might
be gone this time. He’s being taken to the
coroner this time, not the ambulance. I doubt
the coroner would be called unless some medical
professional was really sure that he was dead.
– [Amber] Dewey had to die to make it real.
To show that this wasn’t just some bullsh*t,
cash-in, run of the mill sequel.
– Well, this is awkward.
It also fits the blueprint of a requel. When
the cast is talking about requels, Mindy brings
up Star Wars: The Force Awakens as an example.
There will be spoilers for Star Wars: The
Force Awakens here, so if you don’t want
to hear them, skip forward to the next chapter.
The Force Awakens is all about passing the
torch to a new set of characters. Luke, Leia
and Han are passing it off to Rey, Fin and
Poe. This is accentuated by the death of a
legacy character: Han Solo. So Scream (2022)
is doing the same here by killing off Dewey
as the torch is passed from Sidney, Dewey
and Gale to Sam, Tara, Mindy and Chad.
And just as The Force Awakens brought back
familiar locations like The Millenium Falcon
and The Starkiller, which is basically The
Death Star, Scream (2022) brings back the
Macher household, which plays host to another
party, which is probably the most tasteless
thing ever, considering it’s supposedly
supposed to honor their friend Wes, but it
looks like a typical college party. I guess
it’s kind of fitting though, considering
the existence of this movie.
Here we see a few more callbacks. The basement
fridge is the new garage fridge.
– Not many people have basements in California.
– Richie is wearing a blue plaid shirt, just
like former Woodsboro killers Billy Loomis
and Jill Roberts. When Sidney arrives, the
first door she checks behind is the same one
she hid inside when she donned the Ghostface
mask in the original Scream. Perhaps the most
obvious repeat is the infamous, “look behind
you” scene, which we’ve seen play out
in various forms across most Scream movies.
Mindy is the new Randy, so fittingly, she’s
the one being snuck up on, but unlike Randy,
she realizes it and attempts to get out of
the way. This is partially because she knows
she’s in a movie and she might be a little
bit sharper than Randy, but there’s also
an important clue in Stab.
There are a couple of VHS tapes on the table
behind Stab Randy. I think the top one might
be The People Under Stairs, another Wes Craven
reference, and I’m having a hard time making
out what the bottom one is, let me know if
you recognize it. But look directly below
the TV she’s watching on, and you’ll see
the same three VHS tapes, two of which are
the same two on the table behind Randy. There’s
a slightly better look a bit later, when Sam
is tending to Mindy’s injuries, it’s definitely
the same two tapes.
Mindy, by the way, does survive, which could
be related to this little line from Scre4m.
– [Charlie] In fact, the only surefire way to survive
a modern horror movie, you pretty much have
to be gay.
– [Zac] It also helps to be the daughter of a serial
killer, as it turns out. She may be related
to Billy Loomis, but Sam wipes off her knife
a lot more like Stu Macher.
Now before I get into the ending, and my views
on what this really means for the franchise,
I’ve got to go over all the evidence seen
throughout the film that proves who the killers
really were, as I have at the end of each
of my Scream analysis videos. So let’s take
it back one more time to the start.
In the opening, Tara invites Amber to come
over, mentioning that her Mom was out of town.
Amber and Richie were probably waiting for
an opportunity like this and used it to decide
that this would be the night they strike.
When Tara starts receiving concerning phone
calls, she gets a text from Amber, which says
“you should answer it.” The caller explains
that Amber’s phone was cloned and no one
really questions it. But the easier and correct
explanation is that Amber was just the killer,
using her own phone. When Sam gets a Ghostface
call at the hospital, it’s also from
Amber’s phone.
Amber and Richie have to act like they are
meeting for the first time. We see her look
at him very lustfully, which makes more sense
now knowing that they are secretly a couple.
Sam is attacked at the hospital at the same
time Amber was being questioned by Hicks at
the police station, which means this one must
have been Richie. This is the same old trick
used to get Billy Loomis off the hook in Scream,
get Roman off the hook in Scream 3. When are
they gonna learn that there are always multiple
killers?
Then there’s the scene where Dewey correctly
predicts a killer by accusing Richie. This
is just like Randy in the original Scream,
his first guess is Billy, and it’s correct.
– He’s got killer printed all over his
forehead.
– The most damning evidence comes after he kicks
Richie and Sam out though. Listen to what
Richie has to say about him.
– Jesus! Yeah he’s way more fun in the
movies.
– Notice the plural use of the word: movies.
At this point in the story, he claims that
he’s only seen one Stab movie, the original.
When he and Sam were driving to Woodsboro
he claimed to have no idea about the Stab
movies, and in the hospital, he says he’s
watching the first one on Netflix so he can
be prepared. Lucky for him, Sam doesn’t
seem to notice this slip up.
While it’s not necessarily evidence, I do
think the fact that he spends his spare time
watching vitriol about Stab (2021) kind of
telling about where his interests lie, even
if his reasoning is that he’s trying to
learn about the franchise.
Later on, during the second attack at the
hospital, Amber cuts Richie in the forearm.
We saw this in Scre4m, where Jill was cut
in the same spot by her fellow accomplice
as a way to deflect suspicion away from her.
In my previous video, I labeled this as a
nod to Scream 2, where Derek is cut in the
forearm, and Dewey finds it suspicious because
the cut conveniently missed major arteries.
Despite some of the well hidden evidence I
mentioned, I found these killers to be pretty
obvious. Perhaps the fact that they are so
similar to the killers from the last movie
made them stand out a little bit more.
We close with the same pull out shot of a
news anchor giving a report in front of the
house, but this time it is not Gale Weathers.
Like the main characters and the filmmakers,
the news anchor microphone has been passed
down to the next generation.
At the end, over the dedication to the series’
late former director, we hear a bird call.
(whip-poor-will call)
It links back to all the bird artwork seen
in Amber’s house. It’s all part of one
last tribute to Scream’s iconic director,
Wes Craven, who, in his spare time, was an
avid birdwatcher.
The sound at the end of Scream (2022) is the
call of the whip-poor-will, a sound effect
that Craven has actually used a few times
in his films. In this 2008 interview in the
bird enthusiast magazine Audubon, he explains
how he has used bird sounds as a sort of orchestration
in his work. “I’ve used the whip-poor-will
a few times, probably inappropriately, but
it’s such a haunting sound, and I do remember
the sound from being a kid in the woods of
Ohio and on camping trips. But yeah, I think
they’re used a lot in Hollywood. I would
be the first to confess that accuracy is probably
not the first motivation.”
We get a quick flash of someone in a Ghostface
mask wiping off a knife before the credits
roll, maybe an homage to the quick scares
seen before the credits of Scream
(stinger)
and in Scream 2
(knives slashing and screaming)
No such scare occurs in
Scream 3 or 4. To me, the implication is that
seeing a new Ghostface right before the end credits
is teasing a sequel. We don’t see it in
3 because Roman is defeated, and for now that
means the end of the series. While Scream
4 was not planned to be the final movie, it
was the end of that era of Scream and there’s
nothing in the story that prevents the fourth
movie from being the final chapter, unlike
Scream 1, which specifically has a line about
how there’s gotta be a sequel, and Scream
2, which specifically has a line suggesting
that it’s a trilogy.
So the quick flash of Ghostface at the end
of Scream (2022), to me, is the directors’
way of telling us they planned for a sequel,
and with a sixth movie being given the go-ahead
before the fifth was even globally released,
it seems likely the next chapter was planned
and will tie in nicely with the material in
the 2022 offering.
If you’re excited for Scream 6, you're in the right place because
I’ll be covering here on this channel when
it comes out. So make sure you’re subscribed
to CZsWorld for new horrors every week, ring
the deathbell and select all notifications
so you don’t miss anything and I will see
you in the next one. Assuming we both survive.
(dance music)